bat Superman one B Mark you look like a
Russian figure
skater okay yeah am I back in the
game I can't even I think it's time you
packed up your stu oh I know the line
I'm trying to get my [__] together cuz
he's making me laugh sorry see Mark okay
I didn't steal this from you if that's
what you're employing no you didn't
steal it why stop there why not sleep in
my Mansion drive my car occasionally get
drunk on Brandy and tongue kicked a [__]
thing you want to fire the super strong
super fast bulletproof man who can fly
see through walls and shoot lasers from
his eyes oh you forgot your cool icy
breath uhoh Clark had original Mentos
for lunch and he's about to Exhale on a
villain chilly
breath you [__] suck you make sense
in
1950 and no other time back when
everyone had Polio they were like
imagine a man who could do it all it
gives us hope during whatever the [__]
War was
happening I am a bat you're not a bat
you're a scared little boy playing dress
up distracting the grown-ups with actual
Powers who are dealing with actual
problems I have actual problems really
yeah 99 of I mean a super [__] is about
to not be one of them feels problematic
okay does yeah it's a wonder I haven't
been cancelled you be Mark it's green
tea from Asia not the band the continent
where in Asia Asia Miner oh I had no
idea yeah it's just the Black Keys mhm
it's Asia but the Black Keys not the
band W Pet's falling into a riff hole
[Laughter]
one last thing though do you want to put
your hand in this Shrek doll it [__] my
face you can be like I'm a donkey oh I'm
an ogre I live in a swamp and back when
C I wasn't very a good I was quite
impressive remember when Mike Myers red
the [__] world
I do those were the Glory Days Batman do
you want
to fist this ogre but then they like
Batman somebody once told me that is
ever during Allstar see Mark you have
the rest of the day to pack up your
stuff and leave the Hall of Justice okay
first hold this
rock really just hold this rock you're
not even trying anymore that's how
stupid I think you are I thought there
was a nine out of 10 chance you'd hold
this and start shriveling like the Nazi
at the end of Last
Crusade you have chosen
ble one more time one more time just
hold this rock you're not even trying
anymore it's Rocky and very
holdable now you hold it hold on qu qu
your wait oh I got it I bet you can't
hold this
rock give me two seconds I've been
keeping it together so long um I'm
holding the rock puts an itch in your
brain nothing's going to scratch that
itch like hold
Rock [__] off damn it you look down in
your
hand there's something in
it it's this
R man hold this rock all right give it
to me really no you [__] toddler get
the [__] out of
here go play with your gadgets and your
Legos
suck my
dick he has super hearing so he totally
ear that and come come back in real
quick come back
in what a farwood huh yeah what a fad
give me some of the Asian te you get it
oh God it's [__] rans and I brush my
teeth with more eyes it's my favorite
movie oh
God all
[Music]
right